MIKE DENNY: There's
something really
satisfying about
getting your app
to look great on your device.
But just because there's over
11,000 other Android devices
out there doesn't mean you need
to build 11,000 other layouts
to make a great-looking app.
Not if you're using
Responsive UI principles.
You may have noticed that
I'm not Ian or Joanna.
My name is Mike Denny, a Design
Advocate on the Google Design
Team.
First things first.
Thinking about specific
phones and tablets
is only going to get
you into trouble.
There's a wide
spectrum of devices
and not that much difference
between the largest
phone and the smallest tablet.
Instead, think more generally
about how much space
you have to work with.
This can come in three
different flavors--
width, height, and
smallest width.
Width is super
important and should
be the basis for breakpoints in
designing and building your UI.
For example, 600 dp in
width is the first point
where you could consider
having a side-by-side summary
and detail level view.
Any lower and you won't
be giving each level
the full attention it deserves.
Height is less common when
designing Responsive UI.
But keep in mind that something
like a vertically scrolling
container is going to
be difficult to use
if you can only see one
or two elements at a time
due to a constrained height.
Smallest width, unlike
height or width,
is designed to be rotation
insensitive, as it's just
the smaller of the two values.
This gives you a better idea
of how much space is available
and is an easy way to
ensure that your app remains
consistent as the
device is rotated.
You don't want to
force your user
to relearn your navigation
structure every time they
rotate their device.
This is particularly important
in the multi-window world.
When your app is resized, your
width, height, and smallest
width are going to be updated.
You might be going from
full screen on a tablet
down to what amounts to
a portrait-oriented phone
worth of space.
Here's where a good
Responsive UI can
make for a smooth transition.
There are number
of common patterns
you might consider when
building that Responsive
UI, such as revealing previously
hidden content as the screen
size grows, transforming
your navigation pattern
or switching from
a list to a grid,
dividing your screen into
multiple sections side by side,
reflowing specific
elements, expanding the size
or margins of
individual elements,
or even changing the
position of specific elements
like a floating action button.
Check out the blog post for
more details on designing
a Responsive UI and
specific patterns
you can use to
build better apps.